so he said that you can look to God for
wisdom to make sense of the world
there's a lot of stuff to us humans
that's difficult to make sense of
um like you losing your mother
there's a lot of Cruelty in the world
there's a lot of suffering in the world
uh what
wisdom uh
have you been able to find from God
about about why there is suffering in
the world why there's cruelty you know
there's a thing that I wanted to ask God
about why he allows hunger and War and
poverty but I was afraid he might ask me
the same question
God has certainly given us enough food
there's enough food in the world for
everyone to have a 3200 calorie diet a
day
God has certainly given us enough
guidance uh for us to not inflict on
each other the cruelty that we inflict
when we look to the world around us
first and foremost we have to have a
sense of accountability we are
accountable for our own actions we don't
blame God for the evil of man that's one
but at the same time we understand that
God and his wisdom allows for certain
outcomes that we cannot Encompass with
our own
and that to isolate these incidents
and to try to make sense of them is no
different than a baby in the womb
that doesn't understand the world that
it's coming into and trying to explain
to that baby that hasn't yet developed
its own senses and its own perception of
this world
what is happening to it right you know I
often think of the example of a child
and
you know having
been at this point now through the
experience of
Parenthood I'm still learning I'm just
going into having a teenager uh with
three kids
and being a softy for my kids you know
when you have to tell your child that
they can't have something that they
really really want
and that child thinks you hate them at
some point you know because why are you
stopping me from
putting this toy in my mouth
and choking myself they don't get it
right but at the same time you prevent
them out of love they're not in a
position to understand that you're
preventing them out of love
and to isolate these incidents with God
and to say the wisdom what's the wisdom
uh you're trying to make sense of a
pixel when you can't see the bigger
picture
your mind is not at a place where you
can make sense of the bigger picture you
haven't seen the bigger picture
and so
for him to even explain to us every
incidence
uh would completely defeat the purpose
of putting your trust in him so
we believe in a god that is
all-encompassing in his knowledge and
wisdom
that gives us and Islam is very PR you
know specific by the way that there is
what God tells us to do and there's what
God allows to happen
so what God tells us to do in terms of
the road map towards good and then what
God allows to happen in his Divine
wisdom that no outcome can escape him
but at the same time we are accountable
for our own actions and our own Deeds
so when you come to someone and say you
know why did God allow this to happen to
this person
I can't rationalize that for you because
my understanding is relegated to the
immediate experience in front of me
but if I know God and if I learn about
God
then
I don't have to make sense of the plan
but I can tell you that I trust the
planner
and I think that that's where peace is
found
you know a lot of times you look for the
light at the end of the tunnel what's
the light at the end of the tunnel in
Islam there's emphasis on God and the
Hereafter because to try to make sense
of
ah Divine decree and why certain things
happen in this world without the
existence of a God or without the
existence of a hereafter
will always fail you so the existence of
a god that is all knowing what we don't
know I know what you don't know that
understands what we don't understand the
existence of a God who is not subject to
our constrictions
and the existence of a Hereafter where
all things find recourse where there is
divine recourse
allows for this world to be situated
within the existence of something
greater and not treated in isolation so
when you're trying to treat an incidence
of this world in isolation you're going
to fail and when you try to treat
existence in this world and of this
world in isolation you're also going to
fail and so the emphasis is the belief
in God
a god that is not limited like you are
and a belief in the Hereafter that is
not limited like this life
and so everything continues onwards and
there is divine recourse for everything
each and everything you know the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon it
mentions that
on the day of judgment a person who
lived the most difficult of lives
will be dipped into Paradise one time
and will be told have you ever seen any
sadness any hardship now when you think
about the most difficult life some of
the commentators in Islam they said that
this is perhaps referring to the prophet
job
Ayub peace be upon him because job lived
obviously a life of great difficulty but
that a person who lived a very hard life
would be dipped into Paradise one time
and just with a dip be asked have you
ever seen any hardship have you ever
seen any misery and that person would
say what is sadness what is hardship
what is misery now if you don't believe
in the Hereafter if you don't believe in
anything beyond this life then the
recourse has to happen in this life and
because we see so many people pass
through this life
without recourse of Cruelty Without
recourse of suffering then we're forced
to try to make sense of it and if you
are someone who believes that this
entire world came into existence through
Randomness that were just an existence
of
random atoms that collide with each
other and that all of this comes
together out of nothing
then how can you put your trust in
anything that is greater
so as a you know you asked me as a child
of a parent who suffered
I believe that every moment that my
mother
suffered
that she will be rewarded that she will
be elevated that all of that
made her or contributed to the beautiful
person that she was and will contribute
to the beautiful reward that she
receives and the recourse is certain to
me as a believer in that
so the right approach to making sense of
the world
especially making sense of suffering and
cruelty is that of humility
that we as humans
cannot possibly understand fully
absolutely in fact in the Quran it's
very interesting when God creates Adam
the Angels say to God
are you going to create
uh a race or a species that will spill
blood and cause corruption
and God says to the angels in response
to that question I know that which you
don't know
so even the angels have to Humble
themselves for a moment the Angels who
adore God who love God who worship Him
who obey him unconditionally they are
told
by God I know that which you don't know
and what we extract from that with many
of the early interpretations extract
from that is that
God knows that there are human beings
that will come out of this Enterprise of
humanity that make the entire existence
of it worth it and so just as yes there
will be criminals and corrupt ones
there will be prophets and beautiful
people that come out of this and sages
and saints that come out of this that
show that a human being
who unlike an angel who has no choice
but to worship God an angel has no sense
of will no sense of choice an angel is
created to worship and has no desires a
human being who has the choice of desire
and worship the choice of righteousness
and wickedness that there are human
beings who will choose worship and
righteousness that will choose charity
over cruelty
that will choose service and choose
dedication and devotion
over death and destruction that there
are human beings that will in fact
Ascend the angels in rank because they
will live lives where they choose that
capacity that part of themselves
and they lean into that and worship God
lovingly and Obey him you see in some of
the sages in Islam Scholars they
describe this as saying that the human
being has the capacity
to be anywhere from an animal to an
angel or even worse to be a devil you
know to an angel not in the sense that
we ever actually become Angels or become
animals but that an animal you know for
the most part seeks its desires over
everything doesn't really think about
you know many of the things that we are
supposed to calculate as human beings
doesn't think about which territory it's
infringing upon or you know how much of
its appetite it should fulfill it simply
exists to fulfill its appetite and that
many human beings simply exist to
fulfill their appetite and they choose
that over worship or reason or anything
that is greater just
they literally take their selves as gods
in that sense and their selves have no
limitation on appetite so they just keep
filling that appetite and filling that
appetite and filling that appetite
whereas
a human being can also go to the extent
of choosing something greater
and disciplining their desires
disciplining themselves because they're
seeking a greater reward you know we
know many people that achieve great
things
in the worldly sense
because they choose to study over sleep
for example
they choose to exert themselves towards
their careers towards their education
because they believe that ultimately the
outcome of those Pursuits are more
rewarding than the immediate fulfillment
of their desires
so as Believers we choose that love of
God and we choose that outcome that we
seek and we discipline ourselves to
where we can even Ascend past the angels
and rank now of course I said we can go
as low as an animal or as low as a devil
and we have tyrants
past and present and future as well
that can become satanic in their nature
because they allow their desires to take
such control over them that they not
only worship them but that every other
existing being around them simply
becomes a piece of their own puzzle and
pursuit of their own lordship and their
own satisfaction they will kill they
will discard not because you know and I
always say this it's not that tyrants
uh necessarily like killing people it's
not people's lives uh pose somewhat of
an you know an indifference to them
they're indifferent to people's
existence and so you become
either an object for or against me and
so they're willing to discard
children discard people discard the
rights of others because they ultimately
have chosen that the greatest pursuit of
themselves is the maximum position of
power
and a place to where they can fulfill
what they want to of themselves without
any limits and every everyone else
becomes either a threat or an
opportunity in that regard so we're we
can be Devils we can be Angelic like we
could be animals
we're somewhere on that spectrum and
every moment contains a set of choices
you can make absolutely every single
moment contains a set of choices and
that's where the intentionality comes in
right so the prophet Muhammad as peace
be upon Him says that I saw a person
strolling in Paradise because he removed
something harmful from the road
uh he tells us about a woman that lived
the life in prostitution but that
repented to God when she was thirsty one
day and she saw a dog that was also
thirsty and she said that I was thirsty
and God gave me water so I'm going to
choose to give water to that Thirsty Dog
and God enters her into Paradise as a
result of that
sometimes the small moments with a small
sincere deed
can have a huge impact on a person's
trajectory so every moment is a moment
of choices and
when we choose
belief righteousness a pursuit of
something greater than we find ways to
turn things that are otherwise mundane
and to
miraculous acts right where we can we
can choose God over ourselves and in the
process choose a better fate for
ourselves